Vous êtes sûrement fasciné par les
romanciers, les scénaristes de bd,
les cinéastes... Mais pour ces génies
créatifs,
le véritable talent ça consiste
parfois
à imaginer un personnage et l'histoire qui
va avec
en s'inspirant du plus grand monstre de créativité qui soit...
La nature!
C'est parti pour un petit top de
personnages de fiction qui sont
inspirés de maladies
bien réelles
On commence avec ben grimm, vous savez "la chose" dans les quatre fantastiques
Est-ce que vous savez que les hommes de
pierre,
ça existe vraiment? Ils sont atteint de fibrodysplasie ossifiante progressive
qui est une maladie qui a la particularité
de transformer les muscles en os.
La mutation commence vers l'âge de 2 ans
par la nuque et les épaules, puis elle
évolue par poussées vers le bas du
corps. Petit à petit,
tous les muscles deviennent très dur.
La maladie de l'homme de pierre comme on l'appelle
est extrêmement rare et elle
touche une personne sur 2 millions.
Elle est très handicapante parce qu'elle
touche aussi les tendons et fini par
limiter les mouvements et il n'existe
actuellement aucun traitement pour la
soigner. Attention la fibrodysplasie ossifiante progressive ne donne pas
l'apparence extérieure de ben grimm. Là ça ressemble plus à une maladie
qui couve le corps de tumeurs bégnines,
la neurofibromatose de type 1, ou la maladie de Recklinghausen.
Toujours dans l'univers marvel,
intéressons-nous au cas de groot... Mais non
Merci romain
Groot c'est un extraterrestre végetal
à la forme humaine. Et bien notre brave
gardien de la galaxie pourrait bien
être atteind d'épidermodysplasie verruciforme
qu'on appelle aussi la
maladie de l'homme abre.
C'est une maladie orpheline,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est très rare,
c'est à dire qu'on en a répertorié 200 cas dans le monde. Mais ceux de abul bajendar et ce Dédé Kosware
ont été très médiatisés. Une multitude
de verrues se développe sur les mains,
les pieds, le visage, le thorax. Sans
traitement et dans les cas extrêmes,
les lésions peuvent proliférer, envahir les membres, jusqu'à leur donner
un aspect d'écorce, d'où le nom de la
maladie, qui se soignent malheureusement très mal.
Les traitements permettent de ralentir
l'évolution des lésions ou de
retirer plus grosses, mais on ne sait pas stopper complètement leur progression.
Parlons maintenant de ces créatures de la pop-culture inspirés
des croyances d'haïti ou d'Afrique :
les zombies.  Tels qu'on les connaît
dans les films
ces pauvre bougres pourraient bien être atteint de deux
maladies bien distinctes: le syndrome de cotard
et l'encéphalite léthargique.
La première est une
pathologie psychiatrique aussi appelé
walking corpse syndrome: le patient qui en
est atteint est persuadé d'être
déjà mort et immortel à la fois,
que ses organes sont en train de pourrir
et qu'il est damné voir possédé.
La seconde maladie est une infection
virale du cerveau dont les symptômes sont
un état comateux avec diminution des
réactions aux stimulations
une faiblesse musculaire avec
tremblements et rigidité
une inversion du rythme jour/nuit
des troupes du comportement mais aussi
un mutisme et une bonne pharyngite
Si avec tout ça on va pas un zombie...
On bascule un peu du côté de la mythologie
avec le loup-garou... Sérieux?
Mi-homme, mi-animal, le loup-garou
peuple les romans, les comics, les clips de Mickael jackson, les films et les forêts sombres.
Les experts bataillent sur l'origine de la légende mais si un médecin pouvait
examiner un loup-garou sans danger,
genre un loup-garou végan par exemple, il lui diagnostiquerait sans soute une Hypertrichose
doublée d'une Lycanthropie
clinique. L'hypertichose c'est
un développement excessif des poils plus ou moins localisé. Ça peut
ressembler à ça mais ça peut aller un
peu plus loin voir beaucoup plus loin.
Voilà ça c'était pour le visuel, pour
le comportement maintenant: La
lycanthropie clinique c'est tout
simplement une maladie psychiatrique qui
consiste à se prendre pour un loup.
Et donc à reproduire les
comportements de la bête,
marcher à quatre pattes, pousser des
hurlements et mordre.
Et, pour la pleine lune,
ça c'est juste du folklore par contre, c'est.. non
Allez on termine en beauté avec rien de moins qu'un noble, messieurs dames!
Le compte Dracula en personne. Comme tous
les vampires en général, ce brave homme
présente tous les signes de la
porphyrie et notamment d'une de ses
formes rares: la porphyrie érythropoïétique
Lover!
Les porphyries sont des maladies
génétiques du sang causées par un
déficit d'enzymes et caractrisées
par l'accumulation dans l'organisme
de substances appelées porphyrines. Ce qui donne une liste de symptomes assez
troublante, écoutez plutôt.
Une érichrodontie
les dents poussent  anormalement,
se déforment, prennent une coloration
rougeâtre,
avec en plus les gencives qui se
rétractent...
Ce qui renforce l'impression que les
dons sont très longues.
Une photodermatose! Au contact du soleil, la peau
se couvre de cloque avec des sensations
de brûlure qui poussent les patients à vivre
dans la pénombre. Une anémie, c'est à dire
un manque d'hémoglobine, qui donne aux malades un teint très pâle et dont on raconte qu'elle
était traitée à l'époque en leur
faisant boire du sang...
(une espèce de transfusion old-school...
mais qui marche pas très bien). La
porphyrie entraîne aussi une croissance
anormale des poils, des cheveux et des
ongles, ce qui correspond en tout point
à la description de Dracula dans le roman
original de Bram stoker.
Pour finir, sachez qu'il est contre-indiqué aux
patients atteints de porphyrine de manger
de l'ail, parce que ça aggrave les
symptômes et que la maladie peut donner
des troubles neuropsychiatriques comme
des accès de violence. Alors avouez que...
la porphyrie, Dracula...
Voilà ce top est terminé, posez-moi toutes les questions
que vous voulez sur la santé dans les
commentaires. J'y répondrai en vidéo.
Et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à DTC ;)
Abonnez vous à la chaîne De L'Avidéo TUTO ET GFX !!!